ja hallo auf dem virtuellen seminar
theorien
existenz im sommersemester 2020 ich
möchte ihnen heute ganz kurz einmal
vorstellen und was sie alles rechnen
können in diesem virtuellen seminar wir
machen das über zoom
ich werde ihnen jetzt mal ein paar
vorgänge schildern die sie erwarten
jeden mittwoch von 18 bis 20 uhr über
zoom
sie bekommen eine einladung von mir per
e-mail an ihre campus e-mail-adresse
schauen sie bitte auch im spam-ordner
falls sie die nicht bekommen so gegen 18
uhr als 18 uhr seine temporäre und um
18.15 mittwochs geht es im hinteren
immer los sie bekommen von mini e mail
mit dem link zur einladung da klicken
sie drauf und dann können sie sich
nachdem sie zuvor um sich
heruntergeladen haben direkt teilnehmern
unseren virtuellen seminar zum thema
theorien der existenz am anfang dieses
seminares werde ich alle meine
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer stumm
schalten damit die datenleitung nicht
überlastet ist und damit wir eine
möglichst gute verbindung haben
dann werde ich am anfang erst ein
bisschen ein leitendes sagen zum
jeweiligen thema und dann werde ich
danach die diskussion zu lassen wir
müssen mal schauen wie das klappt ich
habe noch nie mit 50 leuten ein
virtuelles seminar durchgeführt jetzt
möchte ich ihnen aber ein paar
materialien zeigen die sie erwarten in
diesem semester ich kann über so und
verschiedene inhalte ihn auf ihrem
desktop ihrem bildschirm freigeben
ich gebe ihnen jetzt mal zuerst ein
dokument frei was sich sehr gut eigne
zur einleitenden lektüre dass es dieser
artikel existenz in der stent volk
lapidar auch für lasse wie das ist eine
sehr sehr renommierte online
enzyklopädie und diesen artikel kann ich
ihnen sehr empfehlen der ist sehr
habhaft sehr gehaltvoll aber schauen sie
mal durch
da gibt einen guten überblick den habe
ich ins lsf system und auch in unseren
moodle ordner angelegt
es gibt parallel zu diesem virtuellen
seminar noch ein paar andere angebote
für sie begleitend auch digital und
virtuell zum einen den youtube-kanal
philo ist auf dem sie jetzt auch dieses
video hier sehen ich möchte ihnen mal
ganz kurz zeigen was es damit auf sich
hat mit diesem kanal
das ist ein kanal der mittlerweile schon
einige tausend abonnenten hat genau
genommen hat der kanal schon 2000
abonnenten über 2000 abonnenten und ich
zeige ihnen jetzt mal wieder aussieht
der ist also ganz blau gestaltet dass es
unser symbol sehen 2000 abonnenten und
auf diesem kanal werde ich regelmäßig
die aufzeichnung des xoom meetings auch
im nachhinein veröffentlichen so dass
sie sich diesen aller ruhe noch mal
nachschauen können falls sie keine
schnelle internetverbindung haben oder
mal verhindert sein sollten
hier finden sie auch noch andere videos
drauf interviews über das böse aus der
psychiatrischen perspektive oder über
die aktualität nietzsches über kassierer
und so weiter schauen sie mal vorbei es
würde mich freuen wenn sie den kanal
abonnieren würden
da finden sie wie gesagt immer nach der
sitzung nach der live sitzung die
aufgenommene sitzung zum nachsehen
jetzt gibt es natürlich noch andere
angebote das ist nicht das einzige
ich möchte ihnen noch ein anderes
virtuelles medium kurz vorstellen
ergänzend zu diesem youtube kanal dass
es eine app die sogenannte fi logistep
die finden sie für ihre smartphones auch
kostenlos zum einen können sie diese app
sicher herunter laden für google places
kostenlos hat gute bewertung bekommen
ich zeige ihnen das mal ein bisschen
näher hier sehen sie die einzelnen
sitzungen vergangenen semester die
können sie direkt nach sehen oder die
zusammenfassung sich auf der app
anschauen das ist ein seminar für die
hosentasche sozusagen
das gibt es für android aber es gibt
aber auch für andere hersteller wie zum
beispiel hier von apple im app store
gibt es diese app auch können sich auch
herunterladen
keine dass wir empfehlen die hat sich
bislang sehr bewährt ja so viel zu dem
digitalen begleitmaterialien ich hoffe
dass wir dann auch auf dem xoom meeting
übergehen können eine diskussion wenn
wir die diskussion starten werde ich
natürlich die aufzeichnung beenden damit
auch der datenschutz gewahrt bleibt also
sie sehen dann am ende auf youtube
blogger ist nur die passagen wo ich
etwas ihnen erkläre nicht die passagen
wo sie auch selbst zu sehen oder zu
hören sein werden
falls sie noch fragen zum ablauf haben
schreiben sie die einfach gerne in die
kommentare unten im video unterhalb des
videos hinein ich freue mich sie dann
bald im virtuellen modus zu sehen und
mit ihnen zu diskutieren
ich wünsche ihnen dann einen guten start
in das erste virtuelle semester an der
ludwig maximilians universität münchen